>>> DEVELOPING THIS MORNING, NEW
REPORTS FROM AXIOS ILUDING AN
11th HOUR PLAN TO THDRAW
TROOPS FROM IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN,
GERMANY, AND THE ENTIRE
CONTINENT OF AFRICA.
JONATHAN SWAN IS A REPORTER FROM
AXIOS WHO BROKE THIS STORY.
JONATHAN, THIS IS AMAZING.
YOU BEGIN THIS REMARKABLE
REPORTING ABOUT JOHN McAFEE, 31
YEARS OLD, PRESENTING THIS
TYPEWRITTEN ORDER ON A PIECE OF
PAPER THAT BASICALLY SAYS
WITHDRAW U.S. TROOPS FROM, GOSH,
HALF THE WORLD.
WHAT WENT ON HERE?
>> YEAH.
SO THIS REPORTING, WHICH WE
FIRST BROKE LAST NIGHT ON AXIOS
ON HBO IS REALLY DOCUMENTING
WHAT WAS ONE OF THE TENSEST
PERIODS BETWEEN A PRESIDENT AND
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY IN
MODERN HISTORY.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A VIEWER'S
CONTEXT, THIS IS NOVEMBER 9th.
THIS IS SIX DAYS AFTER DONALD
TRUMP LOST THE ELECTION TO JOE
BIDEN.
SO HE'S A CARETAKER LAME DUCK
PRESIDENT.
AND ON NOVEMBER 89th, A RETIRED
UNITED ARMY COLONEL, DOUGLAS
McGREGOR, GETS A PHONE CALL FROM
JOHN McENTEE, 31-YEAR-OLD FORMER
BODY MAN TO THE PRESIDENT.
HE INSTALLED THE POWERFUL
PERSONNEL OFFICE.
HE CALLS McGREGOR INTO HIS
OFFICE, SITS HIM DOWN, AND HE'S
JUST COME FROM THE OVAL OFFICE,
AND HE HANDS HIM HIS HANDWRITTEN
NOTES FROM THAT MEETING, AND HE
SAID, THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
WANTS YOU DO DO, AND IT'S WHAT
YOU JUST OUTLINED.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT AFGHANISTAN,
WE'VE TALKED TO SOME EXTENT IRAQ
AND SYRIA.
BUT HE ASKED HIM ALSO TO
COMPLETE AN ENTIRE U.S. TROOP
WITHDRAWAL FROM GERMANY BEFORE
JANUARY 20, AND THAT WOULD HAVE
COMPLETELY RESHAPED AMERICA'S
ROLE IN THE WORLD, ITS
ALLIANCES, ITS RELATIONSHIP TO
NATO, AND IT'S NOT SOME
FANTASTICAL NOTION.
THE PRESIDENT HAD ALREADY
ORDERED A SIGNIFICANT TROOP
DRAWDOWN FROM GERMANY, SO IT WAS
SOMETHING HE WAS ALREADY ON THE
PATH OF DOING.
SO, ANYWAY, THIS IS WHAT WAS
PRESENTED TO McGREGOR, WHICH SET
IN CHAIN A PROCESS OF PUSHBACK
WHICH WENT RIGHT TO THE TOP OF
THE U.S. MILITARY.
>> JONATHAN, THIS MUST HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING TO REPORT.
I MEAN THIS IS THE KIND OF STORY
LINE THAT THE THREE OF US WOULD
LOOK AT IF IT WAS A SCREENPLAY
AND SAY, THIS IS A POORLY
RESEARCHED SCREENPLAY.
THIS IS NOT HOW THINGS WORK AT
ALL.
PEOPLE WOULD NOT, YOU KNOW, DO
THESE KINDS OF THINGS AND IGNORE
THOSE KINDS OF PEOPLE.
YOU DESCRIBE HOW THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER AFTER THIS
ORDER GOES TO THE PENTAGON, THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, AND EVEN
THE STAFF SECRETARY WHO WOULD BE
IN CHARGE OF ALL OF THESE KIND
OF PAPER PRODUCTS USUALLY, THEY
HAD NO IDEA THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
>> RIGHT.
SO THIS PIECE OF PAPER -- EVEN
DOUGLAS McGREGOR WHO HAS GONE ON
FOX MANY TIMES AND CALLED FOR
TOTAL U.S. WITHDRAWAL FROM
GERMANY, AFGHANISTAN, OR AKBAR,
EVEN HE SAYS TO MACATEE, I DON'T
KNOW IF WE CAN DO ALL OF THIS
BEFORE JANUARY.
HE CALLS ONE OF MACATEE'S
SUBORDINATES IN THE PERSONNEL'S
OFFICE WHO'S NEVER WRITTEN AN
ORDER TO WITHDRAW FROM WAR
BEFORE.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A FUNCTIONARY
INSIDE THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONNEL
OFFICE.
TYPES -- SAYS, I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DO IT.
McGREGOR SAYS PULL OUT A FILE
DRAWER.
IT HAVE THE MEMORANDUMS.
ANYWAY, HE TYPES UP THE ORDER.
ON NOVEMBER 11th IN THE
AFTERNOON, CHRISTOPHER MILLER
WHO IS ON HIS THIRD DAY ON THE
JOB AS ACTING SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, HE RECEIVES BY COURIER
THIS PRINTED FORMAL ORDER SIGNED
BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CALLING FOR A TOTAL WITH
DRAW FROM AFGHANISTAN BY JANUARY
15, TOTAL WITHDRAWAL OF SOMALIA
BY DECEMBER 31.
HE SAYS, WHAT IN GOD'S NAME IS
THIS.
AS YOU SAID CORRECTLY, THEY
BASICALLY START DOING DETECTIVE
WORK AND FIGURE THAT NONE OF THE
USUAL PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE SEEN
OR WOULD WORK ON SUCH AN ORDER
WERE AWARE OF IT.
IT THEN DAWNED ON THEM THIS WAS
AN OFF-THE-BOOKS OPERATION BY
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF HIMSELF.
>> IT REALLY IS STUNNING TO
THINK ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS,
HOW MANY TROOPS, WHAT IT WOULD
HAVE MEANT FOR FOREIGN POLICY
AROUND THE WORLD IN SUCH A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
EVEN BEYOND LAST NIGHT, YOU'RE
BREAKING MORE NEWS.
EVERY TEN MINUTES SOMETHING IS
COMING OUT OF YOU HERE.
YOU TALKED TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND MARK ESPER AND
THEIR RELATIONSHIP, AND IN THE
DISCUSSION YOU HAD, BASICALLY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT THE TENSION, AND HE
THOUGHT ESPER WAS OVERLY WOKE AT
TIMES.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> SO THE PRESIDENT -- BASICALLY
WHAT I DID WAS APPROACHED HIM
FOR COMMENT FOR THIS STORY AND
HE AGREED TO TALK ON THE
TELEPHONE.
AND ONE THING HE SAID WAS THAT
WHEN IT CAME TO MARK ESPER, THE
FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY, ONE OF
THE REASONS HE FIRED HIM IS
BECAUSE HE WAS, QUOTE/UNQUOTE --
HE WROTE, VERY WOKE LETTER TO
THE MILITARY.
IT TOOK ME A WHILE TO REALIZE
WHAT THIS WAS.
TURNS OUT IT WAS A MEMO THAT
ESPER PUT OUT BASICALLY TALKING
ABOUT IMPROVING DIVERSITY, A
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY IN THE
MILITARY.
SO THAT GIVES YOU AN INDICATION
OF HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP THOUGHT
ABOUT THE PENTAGON.
HE HAD THIS -- THE THING ABOUT
TRUMP, WHICH IS KIND OF BIZARRE,
FOR SOMEONE WHO CAME INTO OFFICE
WITH A COMPLETELY NON-NUANCED
VIEW OF MILITARY PARTY WHO
THOUGHT THESE ENGAGEMENTS WERE
WORTHLESS, HE SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH GENERALS WHO WERE COMMITTED
TO THESE ENGAGEMENTS, WHO HAD
HISTORIES IN THE U.S. CENTRAL
COMMAND, AND HE MISTAKENLY
THOUGHT THESE FIGURES LIKE JAMES
MATTIS, GENERAL MILLEY, THE
MEMBER OF THE JOINT CHIEFS,
TRUMP THOUGHT THEY WERE THESE
UNRECONSTRUCTED 1940s GENERALS
WHO WOULD AGREE WITH HIM THAT
TORTURE IS GREAT, YOU KNOW, AND
WE SHOULD SEND TROOPS ONTO THE
STREETS TO QUELL PROTESTS AND
RIOTS.
AND ACTUALLY THESE PEOPLE
COULDN'T HAVE MORE FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREED WITH HIS WORLD VIEW.
THAT'S WHERE YOU GOT THIS REALLY
INTENSE PUSHBACK FROM THE TOP
LEVELS OF THE MILITARY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> JONATHAN SWAN, WELL DON